this truck is on a mission it will cover
many kilometres and cross several
borders to celebrate the 500th
anniversary of the Protestant
Reformation
the six-month celebration tour is
sponsored by the German Protestant
church and we'll stop in nearly 70
European towns and cities this is the
Western German city of forms compared to
this massive Romanesque Cathedral the
tour truck no longer looks so big
Switzerland will celebrate their version
of the Reformation in 2019
how will the Swiss feel about marking
the occasion two years early the tour
also includes a stop in the Latvian
capital Riga where a major dispute
regarding the role of women in the
church continues in the Protestant
community the toughest part of the tour
may be in the largely secular German
capital Berlin while the mission be able
to interest average Berliners in the
history of the Reformation the king of
night with Scott Devine uniqua like he
had done in early December the truck
arrives informs go left then right then
you'll see a big archway that we can't
fit through the city's historic Old Town
district is not designed to handle 17
metre long 30 ton trucks but that's
where the crew needs to go
the Reformation truck has been on the
road for a while now
the volunteers usually spend the night
in hostels along the way 25 year-old
johannes giving is the tour manager he
gets to stay in hotels but that's
probably because he has to work long
after the rest of the crew have called
it a day it's math both I accepted the
position because I wanted to be part of
the Reformation anniversary celebration
from the very start it's an important
milestone and this is a huge project not
just the tour but all the other parts of
it it's a once-in-a-lifetime event and I
wanted to be involved being voted out
even timid building the next morning the
cathedral casts a lengthy shadow over
the truck church officials have
organized a small welcoming ceremony
complete with mulled wine and a concert
[Music]
the truck attracts a diverse crowd
including a local pastor Jeffrey Meyers
he's an American from the state of
Kansas Myers says that the Reformation
is about more than just Luther and
Germany mud spirits it's like we're
living in a time of change you can sense
that it's like it was 500 years ago
under on the threshold of a new
Reformation
I Ninoy and reference your own beer
spirit and we're going through some
labor pains and not only here in the
West the Reformation can serve as a
reference to help us deal with these
massive changes and the fear and anxiety
that come with change but in angst
indeed ones of Mossberg light and that's
part of the trucks purpose it will
record people's thoughts about the
Reformation and collect their personal
stories about it there are multimedia
exhibitions aimed at getting people to
reflect on the significance of the
Reformation a movement that changed the
world Johannes Gerling says the tour is
also intended to help people rediscover
their faith it looks like he's got this
couple thinking that Martin guitarra
Martin Luther got people to change the
way they sing and that's still important
today that man Nick no um tanks on
another one all said he did more than
that he got people to think for
themselves he gave people confidence so
that they could stand up to the
authorities and form their own opinions
Luther said here I stand I cannot do
otherwise
yes he's candy and us Luther was said to
have made that now-famous statement at
the Reichstag in forms about 100 meters
from here this plaque marks the spot
where Luther is reported to have spoken
Johannes describes himself as a
down-to-earth Protestant so he takes a
pragmatic approach to standing on this
historic spot does he hits a canvas it
will be wrong for me to say that it
religious experience for me to stand
here where Luther did I don't think that
you can tie the concepts of church and
faith to one person when they belonged
on past Monday vamos - nampalli you've
got to figure it out for yourself yeah
Susie sabor Klien mousse
you
in the cathedral there's a special
midday ecumenical prayer service to mark
the trucks arrival the Cathedral dates
back to the 12th century and even though
it's a place of worship for Catholics
Luther is also present here in this
stained glass window Cathedral Provost
Tobias Schaeffer believes that if Luther
were alive today he would take an
ecumenical approach to religion
klava I don't think that Luther intended
to divide the church he intended to
reform it and to return the church to
the original message of Christ and
divine grace I butcher from the cuñado
quarters so I think that he would have
been pleased and happy if that had
happened which tanpopo venoth leaving
Verdun regional Protestant officials are
satisfied with the ecumenical service as
a destroyer Victor speech it certainly
didn't hurt that the weather was good
current Sufi setting up so close to the
Cathedral the ecumenical service it all
went together nicely Saturday Angela
strewn in an undercover the crew have to
pack everything up after every stop and
then unload it again at a new site a few
days later it's hard work
the Reformation tour was well-received
in forms because of its association with
Luther the next stop will be harder to
sell
[Music]
it's now four weeks later we're in the
Swiss capital burn the truck is welcomed
with a small ceremony it's early January
and it's pretty cold here
[Music]
you
[Music]
at City Hall there's a reception for the
volunteers yo.hannes enjoys having a
little time to relax before the real
work begins tomorrow it's a tight oil
office yeah I think it's great they've
welcomed us like this well it's also a
chance to talk to a few people before we
get out tomorrow to gather people's
personal stories about the Reformation
hopped off guard with persistent anxiety
the Swiss did indeed experience their
own version of the Reformation here it
developed completely on its own and had
nothing to do with Luther the Swiss are
patriotic they have a strong sense of
national pride if you identify with
Luther and the events that took place in
1517 their version of the Reformation
took place two years later the people of
Bern celebrate Niklaus Manuel as the
father of the Reformation not who Jewish
swingley or John Calvin and certainly
not Luther in Baron the Reformation was
led by citizens and Manuel played a
prominent role he was a painter and
dramatist and often used stage plays to
advance the cause of the Reformation
and now the Reformation tour has arrived
in Baron the truck is parked on the
square in front of the Cathedral two
years prior to the Swiss celebrations
pastor Juergen Schilling is an official
representative of Germany's Protestant
church and one of the people who came up
with the idea for the tour he says it's
fine for both the Swiss and the Germans
to hold their own celebrations as
Matson's we chose a symbolic date the
day that Luther published his 95 theses
October the 31st 1517 everyone agreed
with that decision even a Swiss they'll
hold their celebration in 20 1999 with
you Billy I must begin andres seller is
not exactly pleased about this German
tour he's president of burn Synod
Council still teller says there's no
room for division in today's globalized
world there's lots of religious
competition out there of the London's
item for example we have the Catholic
Church in the unis octa movement so we
think it's important for us Protestants
to think about where we come from and to
look for things that will bring us
together not divide us lock them have
been through them only snuff them
training frock packages arrive but no
one seems to know where they go still
they work out the problem together since
tactical solution
nah man
in gratitude andreas seller shows his
German guests one of the more unusual
aspects of the cathedrals design the
altar and the pulpit are at opposite
ends of the church but people can follow
the pastor's sermon no matter where
they're sitting all they have to do is
flip the seat
juergen and andreas are getting along
just fine
the task of gathering personal stories
about the Reformation on the other hand
is not going so smoothly not many people
are willing to talk about it but
christophe Kunal is and the team uses a
smartphone to record his comments he
helped that's it when I told them about
how in the fourth grade I got into a
fight with a classmate it was over the
Lord's Prayer he was Catholic and I was
Protestant people thus fought alone saw
the clip is edited right away and posted
online now Christoph story about his
schoolyard fight over the Our Father has
become part of the tour presentation in
early March the Reformation Road tour
pulled into the latvian capital riga
riga has been awarded the honorary title
of european city of the reformation so
it's only natural that the tour would
stop here it's Saturday in spite of
posters around town announcing the
trucks arrival and inviting people to
come to a concert hardly anyone shows up
[Music]
poor attendance allows the rest of the
program to be held inside the heated
truck this is Bishop Kirsten fares of
Hamburg she's talking to the Lutheran
Archbishop of Riga Yanis Phonics there's
some tension between the two bishop
fares is upset about the Archbishop's
ban on clergy women Phonics says the
decision is based on passages in the
Bible and on apostolic tradition fares
finds that offensive I'd see a table of
ICC on when I first heard about it I was
really indignant as were a lot of others
and then I started thinking about the
grounds that he cited for this decision
it's dreadfully biblical and
fundamentalist it's a repudiation of
women's spiritual potential vile is not
foolish and it's surprising is getting a
bad idea
women naturally want to know why the
church refuses to make use of that
potential in the religious community and
in the study of theology I thought isn't
shaft Mushaf assist from the fossil the
apostle paul outlined the roles that men
and women would play in the church and
in the community of the faithful men no
throwing in the huggin mine building we
studied his words very carefully on D
hum here please look and that is how we
here in Latvia read the Bible and how we
interpret the Bible
that people don't gain meanwhile
Johannes Goering is in the truck
preparing for the tours next stop they
traveled to a new city every few days
Johannes has to work out the route apply
for local permits and take care of
countless other details how they are
received by the various local
communities is not part of his job that
evening there's an ecumenical service a
show of unity Bishop fares and
Archbishop Phonics walks side by side
the service is broadcast live on Latvian
TV it's a big production
[Music]
representatives of all the major faiths
are here but few people bothered to
attend bishop fairs delivers the sermon
a female cleric in archbishop Phonics
church but she's not allowed to take
part in the final prayer men only during
the rehearsal she assumed that she'd be
included in the ceremony bishop fairs
still favors dialogue to settle disputes
like this but archbishop phonics doesn't
seem willing to make any concessions
[Music]
via Hubble we have no problems with our
colleagues if they have a problem with
us don't have to deal with it themselves
that's missing season it can be lived
forever I think the tours visit to
Latvia was basically a flop the people
of Riga didn't show much interest and
there seems to be no solution in sight
to the dispute between the German
Protestant church and the Latvian
Lutheran Church while the truck
continues its journey across Europe we
decide to take a side trip to Vinton
Berg the cradle of the Reformation we
meet Jurgen Schilling again just as
Vinton Berg was at the center of the
Reformation 500 years ago
it's where the Reformation anniversary
celebrations are being coordinated
the main office is located in what used
to be a school in the middle of the city
this map shows all the European towns
and cities that the tour truck will
visit Jurgen and his colleagues are
discussing tour details
it's an enormous Lee complex project and
every stage of the journey has to be
worked out in advance right now they're
discussing the content of a welcoming
speech that's to be made at one of the
tour's future stops the organization's
online team is in the room next door
Francisca vaca Bhat is in charge of the
tour's website church officials decided
that the tour needed to have a robust
web presence to reach as many young
people as possible so far the site has
more than 30,000 visitors Francisca
takes a moment and shows us the story of
the two Swiss school boys fighting over
the Lord's Prayer it's now online for
all to enjoy
another list assign each other together
we've had a lot of very positive
comments about our website people enjoy
hearing the stories that we post there
and they like to keep track of where the
truck is there's a real sense of history
in Vinton Beck for example this is the
All Saints Church Luther is said to have
nailed a copy of his theses to the front
door today Luther's text is preserved
here on these bronze doors in the
original Latin contemporary Austrian
artist yadegar Azizi has created a
360-degree panorama that represents life
in Vinton burg in Luther's time it
depicts clerics selling indulgences and
Luther engaged in debate here he's about
to post his theses on the church door
but the focus of the Reformation tour is
not on Luther himself Luther is a
polarizing figure and the tour
organizers wanted their exhibits to
reach as wide an audience as possible
Martin Luther is of course Martin Luther
is the key figure for me I was raised in
a Lutheran Church but nevertheless I
have a problem with people who regard
him as a hero and put up statues of him
I don't think he'd have liked that
either today we also know that he was
not without his dark signs shut-ins eyed
and got cut but how can you have a
Reformation celebration without Martin
Luther now let's move on to the tour's
next stop Berlin a majority of Berliners
don't belong to any organized religion
many are only familiar with Luther
because they've read about him in
history books this was where the
Reformation truck was supposed to park
between st. Mary's Church and the
Neptune fountain in central Berlin there
are lots of pedestrians here but local
government officials decided there
wasn't enough public interest in the
exhibit and ordered the truck to park
next to a nearby construction site
[Applause]
and you know stop your nails or things
like that happen everywhere we go and we
just try to do our job the best we can
novel before this isn't the best site
these people are stopping by it's
complex in Lawton in fact Considine come
and see our Reformation exhibition we'll
give you a free ticket for a tour of the
Church of st. Nicholas don't you have it
looks like drawing your pastor band
crêpes is trying to put a brave face on
things
he's in charge of organising the
Reformation celebration in Berlin that's
I'm glad it's a great exhibition and
includes a free ticket to st. Nicholas
Church pastor Krebs is doing his best to
try to get passers-by to stop in justice
to persuade lean arm it's typical of
Berlin
religion doesn't play much of a role in
people's lives here but look at the
immigrants who come here from various
countries they bring their religion with
them whether it's Christianity or Islam
so on an international scale people are
interested in religion but most
Berliners just don't care about it we do
religion is an important part of our
life unique you're tying that's really
going I try the city exists the way the
truck is parked also creates a few
unexpected problems a seal or dancing
beaver tend not to draw one's mind to
the Reformation and what on earth is
that hamster doing here pastor Craig
says all this detracts from the
significance of the exhibition
exhibition hard there beyond your Luther
I get now when your trip could discover
some people have already asked me what
the bear has to do with Luther how we're
supposed to interpret that I don't know
I do I've thought about whether there's
some sort of connection do Luther under
there actually have anything in common
what sounds even and odd so truly I
looked out on the idea this is about as
good an explanation as we're likely to
get then via knew of Luther focusing on
Zambia if we were to focus exclusively
on Luther people in other countries
would complain what about Calvin and
and housing in denmark the protestant
church officials had to deal with all
that when they started planning this
project I think at first they wanted to
include Luther but the Swiss said
there's a little more to the Reformation
than just him boy
but the Luther souvenirs are popular
they can be had for a small donation
guys okay more video tests there's a lot
of interest in the Playmobil Luther it's
just flying off the shelves
this week I'm magneto hating V Johannes
curling seems a bit disappointed right
now Berlin is his hometown and his
exhibition has been sidelined here but
the show must go on and the tour will
travel to lots of other towns and cities
he tells us what he's learned after
several months on the road but if we can
omaha main thing that I've learned is
that the Protestant church in Europe is
extraordinarily diverse but they all
want the same thing it's all about the
church faith and the Reformation
particularly in this anniversary year
for me present for me personally I've
been able to experience Europe not as a
political entity but as a community of
people who bring life to this continent
port even this gives me the courage to
hold on to this European ideal and to
keep pursuing it when he's a forbidden
oil for mineral shopping to skip yeah
that's not only very important for me
personally it's also important for
people of my generation vital to folding
when tagging of historical evidences
through many generations and hiding for
me the one thing I've lived since I've
been with the talk is that we have to
rediscover Europe together openness more
demands on the unfamiliar and technical
the Reformation anniversary tour will
continue till the end of May the final
stop will be Vinton back then all the
material gathered in conjunction with
the traveling show will become part of
an international exhibition a collection
of stories large and small about a
movement that changed the course of
Christianity
you